let's get into audience questions for
the week some very important ones
including our first question today about
reverse racism which asks hey David does
reverse racism exist and what is it I
have been hearing about reverse racism
but I don't exactly understand how it is
different from just racism so let's go
through this in sort of three parts
first what do we mean when we say racism
let's start there
dictionary definition it serves our
purposes well enough
racism is prejudice discrimination or
antagonism directed against someone of a
different race on the belief that one's
own race is superior
I think the superiority part is
sometimes not so explicit but it is sort
of implicit if you're making a criticism
or arguing for the discrimination or
antagonism of someone based on their
race it sort of is implicit in that that
it's because their race is at least in
some way not as good that's racism
reverse racism usually is meant to refer
to when the people normally being
discriminated against on the basis of
race are being racist against some other
group which may also be a minority or
discriminated against group or sometimes
against the agent identity right and not
Asia and agent AG ent so you would say
that in the United States the agent
racial identity the sort of de facto
around which our concepts of race our
base are the majority white population
of the United States if whites are being
discriminated against on the basis of
race sometimes one would call that
reverse racism
sometimes reverse racism can also apply
to like if Latinos are discriminating
against African Americans both groups
that are often discriminated against one
discriminating against another I think
that this is not a useful concept and I
know that there are people who were
going to reach out to me and say David
no it's important to have the concept of
reverse reverse racism because the
dynamics are different in terms of the
power that different groups hold and
it's relevant to identify if something
is racist or reverse racism no it waters
down the concept of racism it becomes a
political football and it becomes
similar to the term regressive left and
what s
aw have become so regressive left at one
point I think did accurately describe a
supposedly or ostensibly progressive
person who is failing to actually be
progressive right the regressive left
means people call themselves left
wingers but they are authoritarian or in
other ways adhere to ideologies that are
not actually progressive it has become
totally devalued and now is just a way
for the right and even for the left so
just attack ideas on the left that they
don't like that's a regressive idea
you're part of the regressive left in
the same way let's assume with peace and
love that at one point reverse racism
really had a very specific and narrow
meaning and was a useful concept at this
point the term reverse racism does not
serve us it does not serve real serious
discussions about race if something is
racist it is racist I don't care who's
doing it it should be called out
typically discriminated against groups
can be racist and so can white Christian
men or whatever agent identities whites
straight Christian men no matter what
your identity is you can be racist and
then if you want to talk about power
dynamics because there is an element of
power dynamics in race you can discuss
whether that racism on behalf of whoever
is espousing it is being put into
practice in some way but I think that
the concept of reverse racism is not one
that is useful to the left and it's
really important not to let the right
get away with using it either yeah I
think a lot of these terms like
regressive left and reverse racism
they're just there to save you a few
words like you don't have to go into too
much explanation because the word the
word or phrase kind of tells you all you
need to know
I don't think reverse racism saves you
that many words though if you want to
say if you were trying to imply that
it's racism against white people that's
all you gotta say I mean is it really
that's big of a difference I I tend to
agree I don't know that it really saves
us that much you know sometimes we say
people's stereotype because since there
are seven billion people on the planet
or however many there are
we don't know everybody so we try to
find patterns which we can use to allow
us to sort of skip to
making assessments about a person that's
sort of the point of stereotyping
inherently it's very often wrong it very
often leads to bad decisions or bad
policy or bad ideas but that's sort of
the objective of stereotyping when we
think about reverse racism as a way to
characterize a particular type of racism
I don't think it saves us a particularly
significant amount of time and I don't
even think it provides value as a
concept so don't use it don't allow the
right to use it to argue for example
against affirmative action there's a
history of the term reverse racism being
used to argue against affirmative action
argue for or against affirmative action
on the merits not by using buzzwords
like reverse racism and if people ask
can there be racism against a majority
group group sure that's called racism
whatever the majority group is there can
be racism we simply don't need the term